ah we're lying about setting up a tax
enter key to running a successful black
bag operation is plausible deniability
she's why I stole all this [ __ ] from the
FBI things go tits up those chicken
dicks can deal with the fallout glad to
see you haven't lost your touch if
there's one thing I'm good at its
[ __ ] with Hoover's ferry brigade well
you were convalescing I did some digging
around wanted to see if there are any
local assets for you to recruit I came
up with three possibilities right now my
priority is getting the hollow out from
whoever ended up with it figured as much
patience well I thought they fell apart
after up a bucket down lucky for us
they're back up and they're none too
pleased at Sal gave del rey hollow to
the Dixie Mafia Dixie Mafia Georgie's
idea it's got him running heroin trying
to get everybody hooked [ __ ] I'll be
damned if I let those crew NASA's
destroy everything that Sammy built up
who replace Baca unknown man should keep
his identity a secret unknown even to
john donovan never thought I'd see the
day well I can't help it if I was born
Pig mentally challenged so you telling
me my only option is a tail one of these
haitians hope he leads me back to the
mysterious leader hey it's better than
no options once you've ingratiating
yourself with them you come see me I'm
finishing something up you're gonna want
to see
maybe I'm done here
don't work too hard man
what time you get home
no see how the feeling you think where
are my shoes gonna bare do we
heard they're flying James el rey back
this week still amazes me they expect us
to believe it was one man who didn't dr.
King it's too easy too bad let's say he
was the one who shot dr. king just him
and no one else what if it's really that
easy to strike down a great man like dr.
King President Kennedy brother Malcolm
then nothing in this country will ever
change now you struggle and you sweat
and someone can take it all away just
like that
brown sugar you sure look and sleep
today
penis if that don't work we just take a
sledgehammer to the whole goddamn team
for true
surprises me the most is how much these
mother's love black [ __ ] these crackers
love in sleeving african women this
cadet speak from the start you do
understand what we're doing here right
Fred in fact that fight fighting for
freedom who did freedom don't mean [ __ ]
without bow on bro yeah yeah comp run
and that's what doggies loves to give us
power they are the key to unlocking the
power for ourselves for these Dixie boys
do are they do why they do it's alright
you
ah yeah we all want Dixie out of the
hollow give me your boss that I'll make
it happen [ __ ] [ __ ] get to the Voodoo
shop you'll find the boss there sorry
about the headache brother
you
too slow
a little
maybe
dr. King is assigned an on file
anybody want some clouds you just got
high
I got some alcohol small
you
coffee nice trick you pulled back at the
Haitian camp tenon baka was holding you
prisoner and I yelled you I did it
appears we both full of surprises
certainly does what can I do for you
link and play I want you to help me kill
Salman Khan oh I see a few months ago
you're just trying to kill me now you
break in here inspect me to trace you
now that McConnell's backing the Dixie
Mafia it's only a matter of time till
they come for you when they do they'll
kill everyone standing in their way yes
I here to my house to your wagon so to
speak I'll see to it that you get the
hollow after that depends on how things
shake out
do you know why I see me now at war on a
county you going after the lottery
please just because you don't want to
face some uncomfortable troops ain't a
reason act naive Sam and I were fighting
because the people in dejala deserved
better than a two-faced old man who
handed out cans of food whenever the
mood hit him who always did what Sal
markaana told him to do even if it
pitted him against his own people he did
the best he could get his best didn't
amount to much dick once I have to hover
I run it as I see fit no questions asked
long as you give me access to your
muscle your connections in a place to
hold up from time to time who can do
what you want
my Connor would place Sammy what a man
named Richard do said do you know of
them assume he's Dixie mom he's a wuss
ter likes to kidnap black teenagers and
take him out to the bayou after starving
him for a few days he cuts them loose
tells him to run sometimes he brings out
the dogs you know whole time sick
that's how we kill my sister this is all
I have left how do I fun it's still
dangerous around here phone so he stays
on the move but his men operate out of
the community change in the old theater
pearl is it used to be called it was
named after Sammy's wife I'm taking it
down first what am I men have been
staking it out see him what he can learn
about how it's being run you should talk
to him see what he knows once I deal
with it I'll see about the church